how do you achieve time where you can
focus and truly think through problems I
do little thinking Retreats so for this
is not the only I I can do that all day
long I'm very good at focusing I'm very
good at um you know I'm I don't keep to
a strict schedule like my meetings often
go longer than I plan for them to
because I believe in wandering I my
perfect meeting starts with a crisp
document so the document should be
written with such Clarity that it's like
angels singing from on high I like a
crisp document and a messy meeting and
so the meeting is about like asking
questions that nobody knows the answer
to and and and and trying to like wander
your way to a solution and um uh because
like and that is if when that happens
just right it makes all the other
meetings worth while it feels good it
has has a kind of beauty to it it has an
aesthetic Beauty to it and and you get
real breakthroughs in meetings like that
can you actually describe the the crisp
document like this is one of the
legendary aspects of Amazon uh of the
way you approach meetings is this the
six-page memo maybe first describe the
process of running a meeting with memos
and meetings at Amazon and blue origin
are unusual when we when we get new when
new people come in like a new executive
joins and they're a little taken aback
sometimes because the typical meeting
will start with a six-page narratively
structured memo and we do study hall for
30 minutes we sit there silently
together in the meeting and read take
notes in the
margins and then we then we discuss and
the Reason by the way we do study you
could say I would like everybody to read
these memos in advance but the problem
is people don't have time to do that and
they end up coming to the meeting having
only skimmed the memo or maybe not read
at all and they're trying to catch up
and they're also bluffing like they were
in college having pretended to do the
reading yeah exactly it's better just to
carve out the time for people so now
we're all on the same page we've all
read the memo and now we can have a
really elevated discussion and this is
so much better from having a slideshow
presentation you know a PowerPoint
presentation of some kind where there
that has so many difficulties but one of
the problems is Powerpoint is really
designed to persuade it's kind of a
sales tool and internally the last thing
you want to do is sell you want to again
you're truth seeking you're trying to
find truth and the other problem with
PowerPoint is it's easy for the author
and hard for the audience and a memo is
the opposite it's hard to write a
six-page memo a good six-page memo might
take two weeks to write you have to
write it you have to rewrite it you have
to edit it you have to talk to people
about it they have to poke holes in it
for you you write it again it may take
two weeks so the author it's really a
very difficult job but for the audience
it's much better so you can read a half
hour and you know there are little
problems with PowerPoint presentations
too you know senior Executives interrupt
with questions halfway through the
presentation that question is going to
be answered on the next slide but you
never got there where if you read the
whole memo in advance you you know I
often write lots of questions that I
have in the margins of these memos and
then I go across them all out because by
the time I get to the end of the memo
they've been answered that's why I save
all that time you also get you know the
person who's preparing the memo we
talked earlier
about um you know group think and you
know the fact that I go last in meetings
and that you don't want you know to your
ideas to kind of pollute the meeting
prematurely
um you know the author of the
memo is has has kind of got to be very
vulnerable they got to put all their
thoughts out there and they've got to go
first but that's great because it makes
them really good and so and you get to
see their real ideas and you're not
trumpling on them accidentally in a big
you know PowerPoint presentation what's
that feel like when you've authored a
thing and then you're sitting there and
everybody's reading your thing you're
like I think it's mostly terrifying yeah
like maybe in a good way I think it's a
purifying I think it's terrifying in a
in a productive way yeah um but I think
it's emotionally a very nerve-wracking
experience is there a art science to the
writing of the six-page memo or just
writing in general too the I mean it's
really got to be a real memo so it means
you know paragraphs have topic sentences
that it's verbs and nouns you can't
that's the other problem with PowerPoint
ver there often just bullet points and
you can you can hide a lot of sloppy
thinking behind bullet points when you
have to write in complete sentences with
narrative structure it's really hard to
hide sloppy thinking so it does it it
forces the author to be at their best
and so you're getting somebody's they're
getting somebody's really their best
thinking and then you don't have to
spend a lot of time trying to tease that
thinking out of the person and you've
got it from the very beginning so it
really saves you time in the long run uh
so that part is crisp and then the rest
is messy crisp documents yes and you
don't want you don't want to pretend
that the discussion should be crisp yeah
there's you know most meetings you're
trying to solve a really hard problem
there's a different kind of meeting
which we call weekly business reviews or
business reviews they may be weekly or
monthly or daily whatever they are but
these business review meetings that's
usually for incremental Improvement and
you're look looking at a series of
metrics every time it's the same metrics
those me need can be very efficient they
can start on time and end on
time